alors alain robbe grillet j'ai lu ce
livre est bon c'est vrai que comme des
11 et c'est très loin de moi
néanmoins je comprends ce type de
recherches je ne crois pas contrairement
à ce que vous pensez je crois pas que ce
soit de la spontanéité
c'est une recherche et une recherche du
tireur la preuve c'est que vous ne
parlez pas de la même façon
donc il y à la recherche de quelque
chose et il ya quand même aussi là c'est
plus les anciens et les modernes il ya
deux traditions quand même dans la
littérature
il ya une tradition écrite et une
tradition parler et c'est vrai qu'on a
cité les derniers céline appartenant à
la tradition parler ou le dernier
solaire dont je parlais tout à l'heure
ça appartient à une tradition qui
justement ne se sert pas du tout de delà
de la syntaxe ce sont des formes non
syntaxique nouveaux éléments mais je
crois que ce sont quand même des
recherches littéraires et même si on
sent très loin c'est une façon
d'appréhender le monde c'est pas par
hasard quoi est ce que vous pourriez
dire le style de evans en ce cas c'est
elle c'est donc le style c'est la femme
en l'occurrence moi joe autant que cette
formule est un sens et c'est à dire
d'accord ici pour faire des réserves
pour le sens est formulée quant à sa
bien exprès il expliqué ah oui mais
comment taire c'est un brontosaure alors
est ce que vous diriez de débats dans ce
cas d'un style c'est la femme elle un
style qu'est ce que ça veut dire le
style c'est l'homme
est-ce que c'est l'homme telles que je
suis né ou tel que je me fais on se on
se fait soi même
le style c'est quelque chose par lequel
on se fait et elle est en train de se
faire elle a eu des dit-elle des tas
d'ennuis avec le monde etc et elle s'est
mis à écrire c'est pas par hasard dont
l'écriture est déjà une tentative de
dominer quelque chose qu'ils essaient
mauvais rapports avec le monde dans son
livre et les temps un tweet en question
vont se hérisse pic même qui est le
pendant de son mec fait la vaisselle
elle écrit
et par conséquent ce je pense que ce
mode non syntaxique et malgré tout tout
à fait acceptable robert kanter votre
pilote